MALE SPEAKER: Today
I want to introduce
to you the very amazing
and inspirational guy, who
happened to be born
without arms or legs.
The funny thing is that
you wouldn't know it
by hanging out with him.
Chris is a man who challenges
what some people consider to be
the norm for a disabled person.
But I think it's best if I allow
Chris to speak for himself.
So we're going to start
first with a video.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Here's is the latest original
short from filmmaker John
Chester over at
Apricot Lane Farms.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
-Everyone knows that farming
requires hard physical labor,
especially in the summer.
Fortunately, we get
a lot of friends who
offer to come and help us out.
But none have been as
memorable as Chris.
While most are new
at farming, Chris
has been farming
his entire life.
But he has a few limitations.
-Things that I can't do--
I can't drive legally.
I can't operate a chainsaw.
Mind you, I've
never really tried.
I can't weed-whip or weed-whack.
I cannot swim to save my life.
You drop a bowling ball and me
in the water at the same time,
I will beat the bowling
ball to the bottom
nine times out of nine.
I was going to say 9 times
out of 10, but no, it's 100%.
It takes me upwards
of 400% more energy
to do everyday tasks than
somebody with arms and legs.
I'm hopping on one leg.
It's a good little workout.
-So what can a farmer with
no legs and no arms do?
-When I tell people
that I'm a farmer,
I'm pretty sure people
are like, yeah, right.
-There were my ideas of
what Chris could safely
do to help out.
And then there were his.
-So how do you break?
-Go to the shop and
get a chunk of two
by four about three feet
long, cut a groove in it,
and I'd be driving this thing
in about two or three minutes.
I'm sure in the back of
your mind you're probably
wondering, well,
how does he do it
and how competently
can he do it?
When I was born, my grandma
actually set the tone right
at a very early stage.
Perfect.
My uncle phoned my
grandma and grandpa
let them know that my mom
and dad had a baby boy.
Healthy, but not
everything was there.
And my grandma didn't even
hesitate for a second.
She said, Bruce-- my dad-- never
did finish anything he started.
[LAUGHS] I grew up right around
the tractors, the combines.
And I'd say when I
was about 9 or 10,
I wanted to start
driving them on my own.
And I've been basically
doing it ever since.
-One might assume
Chris's parents had
hand a hand in developing his
extraordinary independence,
but not in the way
that you might think.
-Talking to my dad,
I asked him, what
did you do differently
with me than you
would have any other kid?
He said, nothing.
So my independence is
almost endless now,
because of their approach.
-There was very
little he couldn't do.
-I remember as a kid being
sent down to the office
because I wouldn't wear my
prosthetic arm at school.
They weren't really for me.
I don't think I even realized
I was missing arms and legs.
-He's not only overcome the
many physical challenges
of his life, but he's
gracefully navigated the most
awkward moments.
-I was handing out
Halloween candy one year
and kids were like,
aw, awesome costume!
I was like, I'm wearing
jeans and a t-shirt.
This is not a costume.
This is me.
Come back here on the
first of November,
I'll be wearing the same thing.
Some people are ashamed
of their freckles.
Some people are ashamed of that
spare tire around their waist.
They have big ears or
a big nose or whatever.
I think if you're worried
about how you look,
you're cheating yourself
out of opportunities.
-Chris's powerful courage
is fueled by the acceptance
that he has for himself.
Imagine, if in our own lives,
we could all do the same.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
How's everybody
doing this morning?
Very good.
I want to first of all start off
by thanking Akshay and Google
for making it all possible
for me to come here today.
I also want to thank
you guys for stopping by
as well as everybody
that's watching
this, streaming from their
desks here at Google.
My name is Chris Koch.
I am from Canada, so I'll
probably say things like
"aboat" and "hoas," talk a lot
about hockey and say "sore-ee"
a lot.
Like I said, I'm from Canada.
And as you can see, I--
born without arms and legs.
There's no real known reason
as to why I was born like this.
And a lot of people
will make the assumption
or they'll ask the
question, it must have been
difficult growing up like that.
And it was actually quite easy.
And two things-- one was
a good sense of humor
that my grandma had
right from day one,
as you saw in that video,
accusing my dad of never
finishing anything he started.
And that really set the
stage right from day one.
It wasn't going to
be, oh my goodness,
what are we going to do?
Our grandson, or my son,
my nephew, whatever,
has no arms and legs.
This is horrible.
It was going to
be, you know what?
We're just take
this all in stride.
We're going to laugh it off.
And to this day, I
still make light of it.
I joke around about it.
When I call and make a
reservation at a restaurant,
I call in and make a
reservation for 5 and 1/2.
My girlfriend
always jokes around
about how I might not
necessarily be her better half.
It's maybe more like
a third, a quarter.
I don't know.
We're not that
good at fractions.
But you have fun with it.
And if you can't laugh at
life, what can you laugh at?
Things happen in life.
There's bumps in the road.
There's hiccups.
And you can do
one of two things.
You can let it defeat you
and take over your day
and ruin your day, or you
can put a funny spin on it
and just say, you know what?
I'm going to laugh this off,
shrug it off, continue on
with my day.
And another thing you can
do is when you get to work
or you get home or
whatever, you can
tell your friends or your family
that funny story that happened
on the way and make them
laugh too, instead of, oh,
this horrible thing.
I mean, I could be throwing this
pity party and everybody I meet
or I talk to, I could be talking
about how unfortunate it is
that I'm missing arms and legs.
No, it's fine.
Life has been
absolutely amazing.
And, you know, what
if our purpose in life
is to have fun and enjoy it?
I think a lot of people
take life far too seriously.
And they forget to just
enjoy life and have fun.
And it's a lot less
stressful way to live life.
And I mean, I'm not saying
that you need-- there's
bills that need to be paid.
Your career has to
be taken care of.
Your children, your family,
whatever-- all those things do
need to be taken care of.
And I guess another
thing I should say
is all the things that I'm going
to talk to you today about,
these are all things that
have worked well for me.
And the way I've
lived my life is not
going to be the
perfect answer for you.
We all have our own puzzle.
We all have our own
pieces of that puzzle
that we're putting together.
You can't take pieces from
somebody else's puzzle
and fit it into yours.
You can look at what
the other person's doing
and say, OK, I see how
that worked for that person
and I see how that
worked for that person.
So I'm going to take
little bits and pieces
and apply it to my
life and hopefully find
the perfect answer for me.
So like I said, my life has
been absolutely amazing.
Growing up wasn't difficult.
I grew up fairly normal,
if there is such a thing.
I played sports
with all my friends.
I got in trouble
for the same things.
Sometimes I got in
trouble for things
that I thought I wouldn't
get in trouble for,
because I thought I
blended well into everybody
else-- well, with
everybody else.
Has anybody ever played the
game-- everybody calls it
something different-- but Nicky,
Nicky Nine Door, Knock Knock
Ginger or whatever?
I played that with a
couple friends one night.
And when I got
home, mom asked me,
so what were you
up to last night?
Or, what were you up to tonight?
I said, oh, nothing just hanging
out with Jackie and Jody.
Were you playing
Nicky Nicky Nine Door?
I said, no, absolutely
not, I wasn't.
She said, well, everybody
in the neighborhood
has phoned and
said that you were.
Because when I run up to
somebody's door and knock
on the door and
then hop away, it's
pretty obvious who
in the neighborhood
was just playing that game.
I don't blend into the
general population,
which actually earlier, I had
to do a quick costume change.
I had a pair of dark gray
pants and a lighter gray shirt.
And as you can see, it's
kind of a lighter gray wall
and a darker gray carpet.
So I blended in perfectly
to the background.
It's not very often
do I get to blend in.
So I still had to
change my clothes
to make sure that I stand out.
As I said before, growing
up was quite easy.
And one of the reasons, the
other reasons that growing up
was so easy was
my parents' hands
off approach-- pun intended--
to how they raised me.
They knew early on that if
they did everything for me,
I wasn't going to learn
how to be independent.
And part of that was made it
a lot easier with the fact
that I was born like this.
I've never known what it's
like to have arms and legs.
I've never known
anything different.
This has been my
normal for 36 years.
It's a long time.
This has been my normal.
And being born
without arms and legs
is really no different than
being born with arms and legs.
You were born with fingers
and toes and knees and elbows.
When you're a baby, you
learn how to grasp things.
Then you learned how to crawl
and you learned how to walk
and then you'll
learn how to run.
And it was just that
natural progression.
And now everything
is just natural.
And it was the
same thing for me.
And I've always said I have
an enormous amount of respect
for somebody who has
lost a limb or limbs
or had an accident
later in life and had
to relearn all those things.
And not only do you have
to re-learn those things,
you have that emotional
and psychological hurdles
to overcome.
And some of the most incredible,
amazing, inspirational people
I have ever met in
my life are people
who have had an accident
or an unfortunate situation
and still not let
that get them down.
And I have an
amazing opportunity
where I get to share my story
and motivate and inspire
people.
And I get to meet a
lot of people who've
been in certain situations
where their ability to use
their hands, legs, whatever
has been taken away from them.
And I just have the
utmost respect for them.
Growing up, I actually used
to wear artificial legs
up until about four years ago.
And I walked everywhere
on those legs.
Even if I was doing something
as simple as going down
to the corner store to
grab a carton of milk.
I'd put on the legs
and it would take me
upwards of 15 minutes at times,
and a good amount of energy
to get those legs on.
There were some times when by
the time I got those legs on,
I was so tired, I just wanted
to take the legs right back off,
have a shower and
crawl back into bed.
But that was just something that
accepted as part of my norm.
Get the legs on, get over it,
and get done what I had to do.
And the legs were-- they
worked well, obviously,
because I wore them
everywhere I went.
They weren't
comfortable but they
weren't overly
uncomfortable either,
and I kind of liken
it to women's shoes.
Or a Canadian analogy
would be to hockey skates.
They're not the most
comfortable things in the world,
but they look great.
I'm going back to women's shoes.
And you wear these
shoes all day long.
They hurt your feet, but damn,
do you look good in them.
By the end of the day,
you are looking so forward
to getting home and
taking off those shoes.
It was the same for me.
By the end of the day, I
could not wait to get home.
And instead of kicking off my
shoes, I kicked off my legs
and relaxed.
So the legs, they worked well.
But about four years ago,
I was down in Florida
and bought a longboard,
just for fun.
Because when I was a kid,
about fifth or sixth grade,
I'd whip around on a skateboard.
And so I bought a
longboard just for fun.
And it turned out
to be something
that was way, way easier to
get around then the legs.
I could cover a lot more ground.
And it was a lot cooler, too.
The reaction I get from
people on the longboard
is way different
than the reaction
I got when I was
wearing artificial legs.
There was actually
some people that I
worked with for an airline
when I was living in Canada.
I was working for an
airline called West Jet.
And there was
people that I worked
with for three years that had
no idea that I was actually
missing legs.
They just thought I was
shorter and walked funny.
So yeah, the legs worked
great, but the longboard
was absolutely awesome.
And I'm in the board, I can
get anywhere I need to get to.
If there is a terrain that's
not overly board friendly,
I could throw the board
underneath my arm and hop
to wherever I needs to get to.
Stairs aren't a problem all.
The board has worked
really, really well for me.
As far as arms are
concerned, artificial arms
really have never
been something that
have been a good fit for me.
I haven't found a set
of prosthetic arms
that I felt I could
maneuver better
than just what I have here.
And a lot of things-- I can do
everything with just my arms.
And there's some
things that-- just
finite little-- skills that
require very fine motor
skills, like
maneuvering a phone--
and I'm going to actually
call on somebody,
if they don't mind.
And I'm going to
issue a challenge.
But as far as microphones
are concerned,
one thing I learned very early
on is I have great balance.
I have dropped very few
phones, surprisingly.
I'm able to longboard
and send text messages
without any problems.
Every one in awhile, you
find a pretty good crack
in the sidewalk and
that will stop me dead.
But I've never actually
dropped the phone
because I lost
the balance on it.
But I can swipe in and
send text messages.
I don't have to use Siri.
As you saw in the very first
video, I work on a farm.
That farm is actually
in Saskatchewan.
She never gets
Saskatchewan right.
So I could type-- I could
probably type on my iPhone--
how's that for product
placement-- on my phone
probably just as
fast as you guys can.
The only thing that I
really have any issues with
is when I'm looking at
pictures or a website.
When you guys zoom in
to your smartphones,
you use your-- forgive
me for not knowing
the proper terminology for the
said fingers that are used,
but I believe it's your thumb
and your pointer finger.
Yeah, I nailed it.
You do that.
I have to my mouth
when I zoom in.
My boss always gives
me grief about that.
He's like, oh, so who's picture
are you looking at right now?
I'm a narcissist.
It's one of myself.
So now, to the challenge
that I wanted to issue.
I want to see if somebody
can, without using
their fingers and
their hands-- I'm
going to get my girlfriend
to come up front here and sit
on the board beside me.
And I want to see if somebody
can take a picture of us
on their phone.
Do I have a willing participant?
Awesome.
Thank you so much.
What's your name?
AUDIENCE: Chris.
CHRIS KOCH: Perfect.
AUDIENCE: Also from Canada.
CHRIS KOCH: Also from Canada.
It is such a small country.
We all have the same name.
I'm from the Calgary area.
You're probably from Toronto.
And it's shocking that we don't
actually know one another.
So I'm going to get my
girlfriend Ally to come up.
And if you can take
up a picture with us--
we want to get you in the
picture, so we'll sit over here
and you can come over there.
So you can use your
phone, because you
might want to use your tongue
and your mouth or whatever.
Sorry, but I don't
want that on my phone.
You can't use your
hands or your fingers.
So I want you to be
logged out of your phone.
I want you to put
the password in.
AUDIENCE: Oh, man.
CHRIS KOCH: I'm making
you work for this.
[LAUGHTER]
CHRIS KOCH: Oh, it's not
a thumbprint one, is it?
I don't have that feature
on my phone, obviously.
AUDIENCE: It's going to take
me awhile to log in here.
Can I log in?
CHRIS KOCH: Yeah, l'll
let you cheat and log
in with your fingers.
But the photo actually has
to be taken without fingers.
Oh.
I'm not responsible for
cracked screens on there, am I?
AUDIENCE: They signed waivers.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: All right.
AUDIENCE: Look at the strain.
CHRIS KOCH: Wishing he
had a longer tongue.
AUDIENCE: Got it.
CHRIS KOCH: Got it.
All right.
Everybody give Chris a hand.
Awesome.
Let's see the picture here.
That's pretty good.
AUDIENCE: Oh, no, we
have to do another one.
CHRIS KOCH: She blinked.
All right, thank you very much.
I appreciate that.
So that's [INAUDIBLE].
Actually, that's the first
time I ever tried that one.
It was Akshay's idea
that we try that one.
I'm going to get
another-- I'm going
to do another exercise,
audience participating
exercise, to kind of put you
into my proverbial shoes.
So I'm going to
get-- Akshay is going
to come down and do this one.
And I need another
person other than Akshay.
And I want you guys to
race and try and get
into the water bottle
without using your hands.
Do I have another
audience participant
to race Akshay on this?
Yep, come on up.
What's your name?
OK, Rigette.
Perfect.
Rigette and Akshay
are going to race
to get into these water bottles.
MALE SPEAKER: That's the
last time I invite you here.
[LAUGHTER]
CHRIS KOCH: It's
a friendly race.
AUDIENCE: So we
got to open it up?
CHRIS KOCH: Open
the water bottle.
You can't use your hands.
Use your forearms.
You can use your mouth.
If you have that much
dexterity with your feet,
you're more than welcome to
use your feet if you want.
You just can't use your hands.
On your mark, get set, go.
Oh, wow.
That's pretty good.
And surprisingly little
water on the floor.
Awesome, and congratulations.
Well, OK, Rigette won.
Congratulations.
And you won a free
bottle of water,
which actually was provided
by Google for free anyway.
So give these guys a hand.
[APPLAUSE]
I'm going to show you
guys another video.
[BEGIN PLAYBACK]
-Notice, all by
himself on a T bar.
It's interesting, not
having any arms and legs.
It's quite fantastic
for this little boy
to be able to go up the hill
and come down by himself.
-The gracefulness of a cat
and the speed of a mongoose.
Today I've just been
moving around some bales
with a tractor.
So come on in.
I'll show you how
to work a tractor.
A lot of the new tractors, it's
all hydrostatic transmission.
So you don't need feet at
all to run these things.
It works out well for me.
When I was a little,
little kid, I
used to ride on the tractor
on the combine for hours.
Finally I got sick of having
to have somebody in the tractor
with me, so I just
said, you know what?
I'm just going to
do this by myself.
If I can go snowboarding,
why not you?
If I can go surfing in
Brazil, why not you?
The possibilities are endless.
Enjoy.
[END PLAYBACK]
CHRIS KOCH: So I was
asked a while ago
if I had the perfect job in
the world, what would it be?
And my honest answer
to that question
is, I'm doing it right now.
I get to travel around
the world, share my story,
and inspire and motivate.
And I've had the opportunity
to speak at down here
at the States now,
speaking at Google--
and that's amazing-- all
across Canada, Australia,
Nepal, and Cambodia.
And it's so awesome to
have the opportunity
to see so many
places in the world
and meet so many
incredible people.
And I love doing that.
But I also love
working on the farm.
It's something that
I grew up doing,
and it's just something
that-- it's in your blood.
You can't really explain
why you love it so much.
And there's lot of people like,
how could you possibly stand
sitting in a tractor for
12, 14, 18 hours a day?
I love it.
And actually, a lot
of my great ideas
or maybe not so great
ideas with my presentations
come to me in the tractor.
You get lot of time to reflect.
And it's a nice
juxtaposition of a life.
It's hectic.
It's life on the road.
It's airports and
stuff like that.
And it's just a nice, calm
peacefulness of the farm.
And I love it.
And the other reason why
I love farming is it's
not a job that you expect
a guy without arms and legs
to be doing.
And I love that wow factor.
I love when I can tell
somebody at an airport when
they ask what I do, that I drive
large combines and tractors.
And they're like, really?
Or when I'm passing by somebody
in one of those machines.
And you can see in the picture
that the cab is all glass.
It's all window and it's a
very narrow steering column.
So when I drive
by in the tractor
and you pass me and I
give you a big wave,
you can clearly
see the guy in that
machine has no arms no legs.
And there's a lot of very
perplexed, confused looks
as to what they just saw.
The other reason why I
love being on the farm
is, it's one of the
few jobs that you
can do where you can spend so
much time with your family.
And one of my other
actions in my life
is my incredible, amazing
family that I have.
And I wouldn't be
in the position
that I am today without
my family's support
and them doing such an
amazing job of raising me.
Some might argue that they maybe
didn't do the greatest job.
No, I'm kidding.
They did an amazing job.
I have an amazing
family, amazing community
that I grew up in in
southern Alberta-- Nanton,
about an hour south of Calgary.
As far as I'm concerned,
it's the best place
in the world to have grown up.
Some of you may argue and
say that where you grew up
is the best place in the world.
And I'm sorry, but you're wrong.
It's Nanton.
I'm telling you.
But no, I do get back home
quite often to help on the farm
as well spend time with
my nephews and my niece.
I have two nephews and a niece.
That little guy in
the picture, Braden,
he's a little over two now.
Loves riding around in
the tractor with me.
He'd ride around for
hours if you let him.
And then there's
also a set of twins
and they just turned one
here a long time ago.
And I have not been able to get
a picture of all three of them.
And anybody who has kids
or nieces or nephews
especially, that many in such
a short, young age range, it
is impossible to get
them all settled down
for one good picture.
One's usually crying.
The other one's usually
looking the other way.
And the other one's usually
got a finger up their nose.
A lot of people
find-- for me, I find
what I do to be fairly
normal, I guess.
I live a regular life.
I just do what I do.
And in doing what
I'm doing, I've
had the opportunity to meet
some incredible people.
One of those people is my
absolutely amazing girlfriend.
She's incredibly beautiful.
And she's incredibly beautiful
outside as well as inside.
And we've had an
opportunity in the time
that we've been together
to travel around, meet
some amazing people, see
some beautiful places.
That's one of my favorite
pictures of us right there.
And not only is it just blessed
to have an amazing girlfriend,
but she works a lot
with me in helping me
with my presentations.
She also helps me a lot in
this whole "If I Can" movement,
I guess, foundation, of getting
out there and encouraging
people to get out there and
live life to the fullest.
And so I'd also like to
take this opportunity
to brag about how we met.
We started dating on Valentine's
Day, which is very Hallmark.
And part of the reason is
just so we remember when
our anniversary is going to be.
The whole world advertises when
our anniversary is coming up,
so it's perfect.
You'll never forget that.
But also, I like to brag
about our first kiss.
It was epic.
Now, growing up in the small
town of southern Alberta
in the prairies, this
doesn't happen very often.
It was on the beach in Malibu,
underneath the moonlight.
It was absolutely perfect,
so I had to brag about that.
It's my stage.
I can talk about
whatever I want, right?
That brings me to
the whole theme
or the motto of what I speak
about, which is "If I Can."
It's pretty simple.
And a guy without
arms and legs, myself,
if I can longboard, if
I can travel the world,
if I can work on the farm,
if I can snowboard, surf--
if I can do all these
things, absolutely anybody
is capable of anything.
One of the obstacles that
we encounter in our lives
are ones that we
have made ourselves.
Or if it is a
legitimate obstacle,
we turn that obstacle
into something
that's maybe this big
into something that's
seemingly insurmountable.
Now if I was taller
and I had arms,
the difference would be much
greater, of greater effect.
So you're just going to have
to do the extrapolation for me.
But it's true.
And there's times
where I wake up
and I'm not quite
feeling it for that day,
and just those
little tiny things
happen to throw your day off.
And they're so
trivial, seemingly
nothing things that happen.
But on a day when
you're not feeling it,
it just gets blown
out of proportion.
All of a sudden, you're
having a crappy day.
You just need to stop and slow
yourself down and realize, OK,
everything's going
to be all right.
And you can look at
things that you've
done in your past to apply
the whole "If I Can" model.
Look at obstacles and challenges
that you've faced and overcame
in your lives and
apply those to things
that you might
encounter moving forward
and say, well, if
I was able to do--
if I was able to land a job at
Google, if I was able to bust
my butt in university to
get that degree that I got,
if I was able to run that
marathon that I did--
whatever-- I've got the power.
I've got the fuel moving
forward to accomplish
absolutely anything.
"If I Can" originally
started off
as an idea for a travel show.
A good buddy of mine,
J.R., he took off
traveling through Asia.
He started in Thailand,
worked his way
all the way down through
Cambodia, Malaysia,
Philippines, all the way down
to Australia, New Zealand
all the way back up
to Mongolia and China.
He was gone for 18 months.
And I watched his travel
posts like a hawk.
And I thought,
traveling like that is
something I would love to do.
And we got back from
his trip, I asked him.
I said, do you think
I'd be able to travel
in that same capacity?
He said, absolutely.
There's no reason why
you wouldn't be able to.
So I thought, let's
put it to the test
and actually see
if I can do that.
And I also thought it would be
a neat idea for a travel show.
So we headed down to Brazil.
And the deal was,
while we're in Brazil,
anything that had to be
done, I had to do on my own.
If I had to lug my 35-pound
backpack 15 blocks to the bus
station and load that
up on the bus myself,
then that's what had to be done.
And now this talk is
going to be recorded.
So I have to make sure that I
stick with those numbers now.
Because a year from now, it's
going to be a 45-pound backpack
and I had to carry
that 35 blocks
and load it up onto
a double decker bus.
But J.R. probably looked like
the worst friend in the world.
And I'm struggling to get
my backpack up on the bus
and random strangers are
jumping in, trying to help out.
And J.R.'s going, no, no, no.
Leave him alone.
He can do it.
Meanwhile, he's just standing
there holding the video camera,
telling these people,
he might fall.
This is true.
But if he does, I got
the camera rolling.
And Ally has said
the same thing too.
And I'm often so oblivious
to what goes on around me.
I've had surprise parties thrown
for me and not even realized.
But I digress.
But she has noticed when
I'm skateboarding along
and I get to a curb and I pick
up the board and lift it up,
throw it up on a
curve and jump up,
or I carry my own
board up the stairs,
or get myself up into a
chair in a restaurant,
and when people realize that
Ally and I are together--
and actually they
also don't always
assume that we're
together, together.
They make the assumption,
oh, what a nice sister
he has, or what a nice
helper he has-- oh, that's
an amazing girlfriend
that I have-- but don't
realize that we're
together and she's
letting me do my own thing.
She knows that if she jumps
in-- if I need help, I'll ask.
She doesn't need to jump
in and just help me out.
I'm good to go.
So yeah, same thing, people not
helping me out and people I'm
with not helping me out and
they look like bad people.
But I would much rather that.
And people often ask
me if I need help.
And I'll say, no, it's OK.
And then they feel like
they've offended me.
I would much rather
graciously and politely say,
you know what?
I'm good.
I got it.
Thank you very much
for helping, than be
a situation where I really
need some help and nobody seems
to care.
And you see all those
videos circulating around
on Facebook and
YouTube and stuff
like that where somebody's
in dire need and nobody
wants to help.
I actually very
fortunately have never
experienced anything like that.
But this next video
is some surfing
from the big waves
of southern Alberta,
as well as some of
the stuff that J.R.
And I filmed in Brazil.
[BEGIN PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
-I'm heading back.
I sure hope those
boards hold me.
-You look like Shakira.
-I haven't missed
out on anything.
-By far today has been
the most beautiful day.
We're just walking into
the rainforest right now.
It's a bit of a hike.
Pretty much just itching
to go in the water.
It's been decided that it's best
that I not go out there, even
with the life jacket.
Pretty bummed out right
now, to say the very least.
But that's not to say that
I can't do it tomorrow.
Anything I do, I want
to do it to the max.
I want to do it the
best as I possibly can.
[END PLAYBACK]
So moving forward, the whole
concept of traveling on my own
in this capacity,
going backpacking
through Brazil or
Australia or Europe,
I've been able to
do that and more.
I've hit five continents now.
The only two continents
that I haven't done
are Africa and Antarctica.
And I plan on
crossing those two off
as quickly as I possibly can.
And a lot of those
trips I've actually
done solo or with people kind
of joining me from time to time.
Or if I do travel
with somebody, I
make sure I take care of
all the stuff on my own.
As far as the idea for a travel
show, that's very much alive.
And I can't go into great
detail, but we're very, very,
very close with a network, which
unfortunately I cannot name.
But we've been filming
over the last couple
of weeks with this travel show.
So Ally and I, as well as a
few of my good friends, J.R.
being one of those
friends who helped
build this whole
concept of "If I Can."
This is from mud run I
did on Monday, in Tracy,
so I guess would be about
an hour east of here.
And it was a lot
of fun, actually.
I'd never done a mud run before.
And Ally had done one before.
We just had a lot
of fun with it.
We just tried to do as
many of the obstacles
as we possibly could.
And I was actually-- not
necessarily surprised
but very excited about
how many of the obstacles
I was able to do without
really any assistance.
And I figured I'd ham it
up with the commando crawl
through the mud, which was
actually easier than hopping.
Because when I'd hop
in the mud, my leg
would just sink far
down in the mud.
So a commando crawl was
actually way easier.
And when I came
off the top there,
I decided to do a belly
flop into the mud.
Ally's shielding herself.
But yeah, we've done
a bunch of filming.
Actually, one of
the amazing things
that we did as part
of the filming is we
hiked five miles
up to the Bridge
to Nowhere to go bungee jumping.
But I'll talk about
that a little bit later.
Some things that I've learned
in life, both from people
that I've encountered and
mentors and people that I've
idolized in my life
and just things
I've come to the
realization on my own--
if you worry about how you look,
you're cheating yourself out
of opportunity.
That one is a Chris Koch quote.
I should put that
underneath there.
I know I look different.
I get stared at
every single day.
But I'm comfortable
in my own skin.
I don't care that people stare.
I don't care that
people ask questions.
I would be more than
happy-- I am more than
happy-- to answer as many
questions as people have,
take the time to answer
a couple questions
and give them the right
answer than for them to make
the incorrect assumption.
Make the incorrect assumption
that Ally is my helper and not
my girlfriend, or make
the incorrect assumption
that life's been
really difficult
and life's pretty miserable for
a guy without arms and legs.
No, life's great.
And I have a lot of fun with it.
And staring is a lot of fun too.
And a lot of people
that I hang around with,
friends and family-- they get
actually way more aggravated
with the staring than I do.
I like to have fun with it.
And in North America
especially, different cultures
approach staring differently.
North Americans try
to be very discreet.
So if I'm longboarding down
the sidewalk and somebody's
walking towards me,
they'll be looking forward.
This is them walking.
And they'll be
looking forward but I
can see them look out of
the corner of their eye
as I get a little bit closer,
and then they're looking.
And I know when I see that,
that once we cross paths
and I turn around, I'm going to
catch them doing a double take.
And then they do this one.
Really?
You were staring up
there at nothing?
No.
I caught ya.
But it's a lot of fun.
And kids-- kids are the best.
They have no filters.
And they just ask
what's on their mind.
And they come up and they'll
stand right in front of you
and just stare.
And one of my favorite things to
do when I worked at the airport
in Calgary is the
check-in kiosks.
I would be standing
upfront helping people
with those sometimes.
And a kid would walk
by with their family.
And they'd pull on
Mum or Dad's sleeve,
and-- Mum, Dad,
look at that guy.
He's got no arms and legs.
And before they
would turn around,
I would hide behind one
of the check-in kiosks.
And there would be nobody there.
They're thinking, my
kid is losing his mind.
I would eventually go
and make myself visible
and let them in on the joke.
But it's fun to have
fun with that one.
But once again, if you
can't laugh at life,
what can you laugh at?
This picture here--
actually a while ago,
I had an amazing photographer
in to do a talk here at Google.
His name's Ben Wong or
Von Wong if any of you
had a chance to come and see
him, or check out the talks
at Google and Von Wong.
He's an amazing photographer
and a good friend,
a mutual good friend of ours.
And now his
girlfriend, Anna Tenne,
she took a lot of these
pictures that you're
going to see up here.
This picture was in a
little village in Cambodia
this past winter, just
behind Angkor Wat.
And we went to this
little village.
And when we first
got there, kids
didn't know what
to think about me.
They were pretty apprehensive,
keeping their distance.
And then I'd let them play on
the longboard for a little bit.
And then I got in there and
I played on the longboard
with them.
And then, I'm going to say it
wasn't much more than three
or four minutes
after we got there
that this photo was taken.
When I walk around,
wander around,
stroll around,
whatever-- and I'm
very self conscious
about how I look
and the fact that I have
no arms and no legs,
people are going to pick
up on that insecurity.
And they're going to be
insecure about it too.
If I just go through life
not worrying about it, which
I don't, and treat
myself and deliver myself
as just like any
other person, they're
going to pick up on that.
And so when I first
got there, these kids
were very nervous about me.
And five minutes
later, I guarantee you
they had no clue that they
were playing with this guy
without arms and legs
on the skateboard.
And it's so amazingly
quick how fast it happens,
how fast the transition
happens from, I'm not
too sure about this guy,
to, this guy's awesome.
I might be pumping my
own tire on that one.
And the good sense of humor
has done very, very well
for me in that.
I joke around and tell
people that I have
a very disarming personality.
Yeah, you have fun with it.
You get into life
what you put into it.
These photos again taken
by the amazing Anna Tenne.
These were in Nepal.
I had the opportunity to
speak with some refugees that
were in Nepal.
And surprisingly, hardly
any of them if any of them
had ever been on a
longboard before.
And surprisingly and
thankfully, none of them
broke any limbs doing that.
I have low center of gravity
on my side, so it's easy for me
to stay on a longboard.
When you're six foot
two, not so much.
You get out of life
what you put into it.
You put out positivity,
you will get positivity.
You put on negativity,
you'll get negativity.
And the best way I can
really bring this point home
is my trip to Europe that I
took about three years ago now.
It was three months in Europe.
It was the first time I'd
ever done a trip completely
solo and on my longboard for
that extended period of time.
And I had no itinerary.
It was three months.
Beyond that, I was
just winging it.
And my mom thought it
was a horrible idea.
She figured for sure something
bad was going to happen.
I told her, everything's
going to be fine.
Nothing's going to happen.
And then when I had
eight hours on the plane
to think about this adventure
I was about to embark on,
I got to thinking, you
know, Mum might be right.
This could go horribly wrong.
I thought, OK
well, maybe it does
but at least I'm putting
myself out there and trying.
But I was playing through
all the different scenarios
as to what might happen.
And the thing that played
over and over again in my mind
as to the most likely, was
people would try to rob me.
I thought, I would be the
ideal person to mug or to rob.
I mean, I'm unarmed. [CHUCKLES]
I tell that one and-- I don't
know if people are not too sure
if they're supposed to laugh
or if they don't get it.
But eventually, they get it,
and OK, that's pretty clever.
Anyhow, if you do steal
my money-- I mean,
I got no legs, so it's
a pretty easy getaway.
But the absolute
opposite happened
when I was over in Europe.
People were literally tracking
me down and chasing me down
in the streets, trying
to give me money.
I'd be longboarding from
Buckingham Palace to Trafalgar
Square or from the Louvre
to the Eiffel Tower,
and people would be chasing
me down-- here, here,
can I give you this money?
No, it's OK.
I don't need the money.
I'm travelling.
I'm good, which was a huge lie.
I was traveling and I
really needed that money.
But OK, I'm not going
to take the money.
After about the third insistence
that I take this money,
I'd say, OK, fine,
thank you very much.
You're far too kind.
You didn't have to--
all those things
I was able to say in about three
or four different languages.
And in my three months
traveling around Europe,
I was given, easily, over $400.
And I firmly believe that the
reason why I was given money
instead of being robbed
was I'm out there
and I'm just having fun living
life, a smile on my face.
I say hi to everybody.
I acknowledge everybody
that passes by,
laughing, having fun.
And they pick up on that.
They're not going to
try and harm somebody
that's got lots of confidence
and is happy and comfortable
in their own skin.
And they want to--
if anything, they're
trying to reward
that positivity.
You know what?
You just put a smile on my face.
I want to give you
something back.
Sometimes it's a hug
that they give me back.
Sometimes it's a kiss.
Sometimes it's money.
Sometimes it's some odd things.
But anyways, it was amazing.
It is so incredibly amazing.
And I'm just going to tell
one quick, funny story.
When I was in Europe,
Paris, got into Paris.
I took the bus from
London to Paris.
And yes, I know the English
Channel's in the way.
But I took the ferry
from Dover to Calais.
Anyways, when we got into Paris,
it was very late at night.
I didn't have any
cash, any euro on me.
All I had was British pounds.
And I couldn't find a cash
machine at the bus depot.
So I got into a
taxi and was trying
to convey to the taxi driver
that I didn't have any cash.
Could I pay with my Visa?
He said, no Visa.
And he took me my hostel
and said, don't worry.
It free-- gratuit.
That was awesome.
Thank you so much.
I really appreciate that.
I got to my hostel.
And the hostel also
wouldn't accept my Visa.
They wanted cash.
And they said we'll let you
stay here tonight and just get
the cash in the morning.
It's one o'clock in the morning.
You're in downtown Paris.
We're not going to expect you to
go around trying to find cash.
I also hadn't had any
food for quite a while
and I was thirsty.
So I was sick and tired
of not having cash.
So I decided, I'm going to go
out and find a cash machine.
So, one o'clock in the morning,
I'm longboarding around Paris,
trying to find a cash machine.
I finally find one,
but it was too high.
I couldn't reach it.
In downtown Paris, one
o'clock in the morning,
I was kind of
surveying the scene,
and people are walking by.
But I just couldn't
bring myself to trust
that if I pull over
a random stranger
and say, OK, sir or ma'am,
I'm going to give you my Visa.
And I'm going to tell
you my PIN number
and trust that you're not
going to steal all of my money.
Couldn't bring
myself to do that.
But I noticed, just a couple
doors down, there was a bistro.
It was closed, but they had all
the chairs and tables outside.
So I went over and
I grabbed a chair.
And I'm carrying it like this.
And there's a person inside
of the restaurant cleaning up
after they had closed.
And the back rest of the
chair was blocking me,
so all he could see was
this chair floating along.
And so he came running outside
trying to figure out why
his chairs were floating away.
And by this time, I'd had
the chair set up at the cash
machine pulling out my money.
But there's a lot of really
good stories that I could tell.
I could go on and on and
on with stories like that.
But it's been an amazing
ride and a lot of fun.
And you know, these
bad things fortunately
have not happened to me
because of, in my opinion--
and I feel very
strongly about this--
the positive energy you
put out comes back to you.
And a lot of times, it
comes back to you tenfold.
The core of man's spirit
comes from new experiences.
And I also say that be more
afraid of regret than failure.
Now, experiences can
mean a lot of things
for a lot of different people.
And I've taken this from the
movie/book "Into the Wild."
It wasn't the
happiest of endings,
but the premise of
what he was doing I
really agree with, but just
getting out there and living
life as much as
he possibly could,
crossing off as many
items off his bucket list
as he possibly could.
For me, traveling
is the experience
that I love-- adventure,
the whole adrenaline.
That's something that
really matters most to me.
Ally, she's not a big
adrenaline junkie.
So the other day, as part of
this pilot that we're filming,
we hiked up to the
Bridge to Nowhere.
It was a five mile hike up
and a five mile hike back.
And I had just gotten
new artificial legs,
because I wanted to
get these legs going.
Because while I
was in Nepal-- I'm
kind of mixing two stories
here into one-- when
I was in Nepal this
winter, we went up
to Namche Bazaar, which
is a quarter of the way up
to Mount Everest.
And I thought, if I got a
set of legs going again,
I'd be able to do this trek
the whole way, all the way up
to Mount Everest.
And so the plan is-- so I've
got these legs going now,
and the plan is to trek all
the way to Mount Everest base
camp as part of a fundraiser.
And I'm hoping do that.
If we can't have it ready to
go for the second half of May,
we'll be looking at doing
this in the end of August.
And so we were, in filming this
pilot, we had these legs going.
And it was kind of like
the second or third time
that I had worn legs and
walked in like four years--
maybe bit off a little
more could chew.
But we walked, or I walked
the first mile or so.
And then the legs
weren't working.
So we had to kind
of bail on the legs.
And between my buddies
JR, Muldoon, and Stevie,
they threw me on their backs
and helped me up to the bridge.
And I was actually feeling
incredibly defeated,
because I want things
to go perfectly.
And I'm not going to lie to you.
I was POed.
And I was, you know,
what's the point, this
is- what a waste of time.
These legs are-- I had other
words that I was using.
And Ally was very, very good
to just calm down and be like,
hey, look at your own motto.
And sometimes you lose
sight of what you're doing.
And you just get too
caught up in the moment.
And I took it as failure.
And Ally pointed out
like, first of all,
how the legs were
going the first time
and how they're going
right now, you're
actually doing way better.
You just walked almost a mile.
So don't be too
hard on yourself.
And this is part of a process.
I'm going back to the drawing
board with these legs.
And we'll get it figured out.
And we are going to get
to the Everest base camp.
There's no doubt in my
mind that we are going
to get to Everest base camp.
I will not stop until I do it.
There's going to be
some bumps in the road.
But this back to
experience, experience
means something
different for everyone.
An event that happens-- everyone
experiences it differently.
As far as the bungee
jumping was concerned,
I experienced the potential
of going bungee jumping
much differently than Ally did.
Ally, she's not an
adrenaline person.
But she got up there.
She did the hike.
I didn't even do the hike.
My buddies had to
piggyback me up there.
She did the hike in and out.
But she got herself
to a point where
she realized, you know, I don't
need to do this bungee jump.
I'm OK with not jumping off
a perfectly good bridge.
Can't say as I blame her.
And she was at peace with that.
That experience was
different for her.
And when I'm talking about
the core of man's spirit
being-- the core of
man's spirit comes
from new experiences, travel
and adventure-- whatever
is what that means for me.
That's how I get
my satisfaction.
For you, it might be painting
or music or trying out
new restaurants or
cooking or whatever.
The point of this is, don't
get complacent in life.
Keep enriching
your lives with as
many different and
new experiences
as you possibly can.
We get in our comfort zone and
we forget to challenge ourself
and test ourselves.
And we forget to remind
ourselves just how resilient
and how incredibly capable
we are of such great things.
And failure is only failure
if you treat it as that.
I'm way more afraid of
regret than I am of failure.
I do not want to look at my
life and look back and say,
I wish I would have done this.
I wish I would have done that.
I was ready to just quit
on the legs altogether.
And if I would
have done that, I'd
be regretting that for
the rest of my life.
And luckily, I have
amazing people around me
to help keep that in check.
And we all have amazing
people around us
to help keep us in check.
And we got to
remember to make sure
we feed off those resources.
That, by the way,
another picture by Anna.
That's Mount Everest and
that's as close as we got
to Everest here in February.
I'm hoping to have--
no, I'm not hoping.
I will have another
picture where
we're right at the base of
that great big mountain.
We-- will have-- Stevie,
Ally, Muldoon, JR,
myself, and anybody
else that wants to join.
So if anybody wants to
come to Nepal with us
and raise some money-- so
the fundraiser I want to do
is for the Child Amputee Program
in Canada, an organization
that I benefited
from a great deal.
They help child amputees
throughout the country
with funding for limbs,
post-secondary education.
And it's also just an
amazing support group.
The other half of the
money that I raise I
want to contribute to
the people of Nepal,
specifically people with
disabilities in Nepal.
When I was over
there, I was seeing
a lot of instances
where they're not
getting the same level of
assistance, and in some cases
not even close to the
same level of assistance,
as we enjoy in North America
as Canadians and Americans.
So that is my goal
and I will achieve it.
This next video is one that
Von Wong did with Anna and I
on our trip in Cambodia.
And I figured I'd share that
with you before I wrap up.
[BEGIN PLAYBACK]
-It's always nice to share a
experience with someone else.
But Chris more than anyone else,
you never know what to expect.
You never know how people
are going to treat him.
I like it because I
get completely ignored.
Everyone's looking at
Chris, so I can just
watch the interaction.
And I really love that.
-When I was young, I would
actually always look at maps,
thinking, I'd love to go
there or I'd love to go there.
I guess I never really
did a whole lot about it.
I found excuses to not
do it, whether it be,
I have work I've
got to worry about,
money I got to worry about.
And finally I was
just like, screw it.
Went out and booked the
ticket and said to myself,
you got four months to
make this trip happen.
-It would be ideal to generate
some income while traveling.
But I feel so lucky that
I can do what I love,
which is travel and
photography at the same time,
I'm helping Chris
make a difference.
He's really impacting a
lot of people's lives.
And people realize that
if he can, they can.
-What drives me
is the opportunity
to meet a lot of people as
well as get to share my story
and hopefully encourage
others to live
life a little more full, get
out and travel or get out and do
something that they've
always dreamt of doing,
but have always made
excuses for themselves.
I was one of those people.
I wanted to travel, but
I just kind of figured,
it's going to be tough
without arms and legs.
I was like, you know what?
Just figure that out and
just go out and do it.
If somebody wants to
travel bad enough,
they can make it happen.
And that goes with
anything in life.
If you want to do
something bad enough,
if you want it bad enough,
you will find a way to do it,
to go above and beyond what you
need to do to make it happen.
And the ability for human
beings to do whatever they want
is absolutely there.
They just need to
realize that and do it.
I read somewhere that
dreams never die.
People just give up
them too quickly.
[END PLAYBACK]
People say that
you only live once.
I tend to disagree
with that one.
I think you only die once.
When you woke up on the
morning of January 1 of 2015,
you were given 365
opportunities to live life
to the absolute most,
to the absolute maximum.
And I encourage everybody
to do just that.
Each day is a gift.
Treat it as that and
make the most of it.
If today's not going so great,
you have the rest of today
to make up for it.
And just enjoy life.
It's a precious gift.
And we're all here to
have fun and enjoy it.
So if I can do all
these things, you guys
are capable of absolutely,
absolutely anything.
I do do the social media.
If I Can, www.IfICan.ca
is my website.
There's links to my
Twitter and my Instagram.
I don't do Snapchat,
because Snapchat is selfies.
And with my phone, I have to
hold my phone up and press
the button with my tongue.
So all my selfies just
end up me taking a picture
of the bridge of my nose.
Check me out at Google.
Cross-eyed.
And then I also have Facebook.
And I have these social
media sites, pages,
whatever you call them.
Every Monday, I try do a
Motivational Monday, something
that I'm up to or something that
somebody else that I know of
or I've seen that is doing some
incredible stuff to start off
the week on a high note.
And then on Fridays, I try to do
a Friday Funny, just something
to give people a good laugh
to finish off the week
and start off the weekend.
I've got all kinds
of corny ones.
I want to do a
meme of me in front
of, like, a palm
reader with a quotation
like, I'm a little skeptical.
That's kind of the-- a
lot of very similar vein.
But guys, I want to
thank you so very much.
And Facebook-- sorry--
is Chris Koch, If I Can.
Chris Koch is just
my personal one.
That's all family and friends.
Chris Koch If I Can is I update
everything that I'm up to.
But I want to thank
you guys so very much.
I want to thank Google.
I want to thank Akshay for
making this all possible
and putting this all together.
And I want to thank
everybody here
in the audience, as well
as watching, streaming
from their desks for joining.
Please keep in contact.
I love to hear some
of the amazing things
that you guys are up to.
So thank you again.
And if I can, anybody can.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Thanks, Chris.
You said you worked
for an airline.
Have you ever tried
flying an airplane?
CHRIS KOCH: I have never
tried flying an airplane
and it's something that I
would really love to try out.
I love aviation.
I'm a plane geek.
I used to work at an air museum
in my hometown of Nanton,
Lancaster Museum.
And working for
the airline-- one
of the big reasons I
got in with an airline
is because of my
love for planes.
So it's something that
I want to look into.
I got a good buddy.
He's missing his hand.
And he flies for
Air Canada Jazz.
And he's one of those people
that I look up to and admire.
And he's got one hand and
he's flying commercially.
I don't know if the passengers
would like to know that.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Hi.
When you travel cross country,
there hasn't been ever any need
for fingerprinting or--
CHRIS KOCH: Fingerprint, yeah.
Like, your NEXUS pass?
AUDIENCE: Like visa or
whenever you enter a country,
they print you.
CHRIS KOCH: Yeah, no, I
haven't had any issues
with needing to
do fingerprinting.
Like when I had a pass so
I could go through security
or bypass security, sorry,
when I worked at the airline,
I did the retina scan.
But as far as fingerprinting,
I haven't had to do that.
And I always find it
funny-- it would be awesome
if I, like, robbed
a bank or something
and they dust for fingerprints.
It appears that the
perpetrator robbed
the bank with his elbows.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Chris.
I'm wondering what you do-- I
love your attitude towards life
and how you exude positivity.
How do you do that when
you're not at your best?
I know you mentioned
you had friends
that kind of helped carry you.
And mentally, do you do anything
daily to keep yourself going,
anything like that?
CHRIS KOCH: Yeah.
A practice that Ally and
I have done every morning
is just checking
in with one another
and reminding one another of how
lucky are to have one another
and how lucky we are to have
the opportunities that we have.
And before then,
it was just looking
at all the incredible
opportunities that I have
and how much I love
people, how much I
love my family-- my
nieces, my nephews.
And when I'm in that funk,
I kick myself out of that
as quickly as I
can, because there's
the line from "The
Shawshank Redemption"--
get busy living get busy dying.
And there's so many
things out there
that I would regret so
much for not experiencing
if I just sat at home
and felt sorry for myself
and threw that pity party.
So I'm able to kick myself out
of that as quickly as I can,
whether it be just getting
out and going for a longboard,
getting some fresh air, spending
time with my girlfriend,
spending time with my
nephews and my niece, family,
people that make me laugh, even
something as simple as throwing
in a movie-- a good
Jim Carrey movie.
That'll turn a
person's day around.
Put in "Yes Man."
There you go.
AUDIENCE: You've
shown us surfing thing
and you've done all kinds
of courses and hiking
in everything, talked
about bungee jumping.
What's next for you?
CHRIS KOCH: What's next for me?
The sky's the limit.
Anything's possible.
There's all those cliches.
I'm pretty much
game for anything.
Yes, skydiving is something
that I would love to do.
I'd love to do a big long kayak.
Mount Everest base
camp is something
that is very much on the list.
And getting these legs
up and running-- Ally
and I are planning on doing
a lot of just little treks
and then just build it
up bigger and bigger
so we're ready for when the
time comes to do base camp.
AUDIENCE: I've actually
been a long-term skydiver.
And I broke my neck skydiving
and came back from that.
And I'm coming back
from ankle injuries now,
and I kayak open ocean.
So it's entirely possible.
You're welcome to
join me in either one,
the Golden Rangers at
Fort Knox, I think it is,
are going to take
me skydiving again.
CHRIS KOCH: I'm all ears.
Absolutely all ears.
MALE SPEAKER: Your
girlfriend, it says,
what are your
experiences in dealing
with others as they
interact with Chris,
both good and the bad?
AUDIENCE: I guess he
kind of touched on it.
It's interesting to watch
people's interpretation
of our relationship and their
reaction to my standing aside.
Like, I'll get a lot of
looks of like, [WHISPERS]
I can't believe he would
just let him struggle.
But I know that if
I step in, there's
no need for me to
step in for that.
So, just an interesting
thing to watch.
But I think when we
first started dating too,
I had some interesting reactions
of people when they found out
that we were dating.
I had people
actually start crying
and just-- that's so amazing.
CHRIS KOCH: I thought
they were crying
because they had dated me.
You sure?
AUDIENCE: It's been
really interesting.
It's a very, very
different perspective.
Anna even talked about it,
being able to sit back and just
watch.
It's been really neat.
AUDIENCE: So how was it in
middle school and high school?
I mean, is there any advice?
Because there's kids that try
to stand out, be different,
and some that they just
plain are different.
And they get bullied and
teased in the younger years,
in elementary and middle
school especially.
So how was that experience
for you growing up,
probably a small town.
But what advice would
you give for those kids
that do struggle?
CHRIS KOCH: Yeah, you're right.
I did have the luxury of
growing up in a small town where
everybody knew me.
Everybody was familiar
with my situation.
But I was always-- like
I said in that video,
there's a lot of times
where I didn't even realize
I was missing arms and legs.
I've always been
comfortable in my own skin.
I was never treated like a
kid without arms and legs.
So I never felt as such.
And it's all about confidence.
And that's a really
tough thing to learn.
And especially middle
school and into high school,
I honestly think it's
getting tougher and tougher
as time passes for kids in
that age bracket growing up.
There's online bullying and
everything is so instant.
You do one thing and it
is magnified instantly.
And also, society too-- not
to make fun of specific shows,
but there are shows out
there where they deliberately
have people in auditions
that are not good performers,
parade them in
front of everybody
just for the purpose
of ridiculing them
and putting them down.
No wonder people are so happy
to bully and write stuff
online about so and so.
My advice-- I guess it's really
tough, because I was never
really bullied.
For bullies, stop.
It's not cool.
You are hurting people a
lot more than you think.
You might come across
as just fun razzing.
But some of that stuff
cuts really deep.
And you catch person
on that wrong day-- you
were saying for me if
I'm having a bad day--
and this happened a while ago.
I was having kind of a bad day.
I went out to the
promenade in Santa Monica
and getting energy of people.
And there was a
couple kids passed by
and they jumped back and
like, oh, look at that freak.
And I thought, really?
Today?
Really not having a good day
and you had to do this today?
Normally, I wouldn't
even notice that.
But that particular day,
I was not feeling it.
And it cut a little bit deeper.
Actually, there's a lot of times
where that stuff might even
happen.
And Ally might notice it but
I'm completely oblivious.
Because I'm too busy looking
at all the positive things
that are out there.
So I guess my advice to
people who are getting
bullied-- don't let it happen.
Tell somebody.
Do not just allow
yourself to suffer alone.
And within yourself,
celebrate your positives.
Celebrate your strengths.
And don't worry about
your perceived weaknesses,
because a lot of times
your perceived weaknesses
are ones that you are
seeing within yourself.
And that, what you're feeling,
you're putting out there
and people are
picking up on that.
If you're out there, you're
having fun and enjoying life,
people aren't seeing a
guy without arms and legs.
They're just seeing a guy
that's out there enjoying life.
They're not seeing a
person with big ears
or a big nose or
overweight or whatever.
They're just seeing
a person that's
out there with a big smile.
And that smile is
incredibly contagious.
That's a very long answer.
MALE SPEAKER: It
says, other than not
watching the Toronto Maple Leafs
play, that was the end of that.
CHRIS KOCH: I'm a
Calgary Flames fan.
And I was making fun
of Maple Leafs fans
at a presentation I was
doing just outside Toronto.
Because the way the
place was set up,
it was just all chairs
sitting on the floor.
So the people in
back couldn't see me,
because I'm not very tall.
And I told them, I'm not
the tallest presenter
you've ever had.
I might not even be the best
presenter you've ever had.
But in a room full
of Leafs fans,
you're used to being let down.
And then two days later,
the Leafs played the flames
and the Leafs won, so
I was eating my words.
I don't make those
jokes anymore.
MALE SPEAKER: And then
there are a couple
of technology-related questions.
One is, what, if any, Google
products-- YouTube, Gmail,
Google Maps, do you
use, and can you
tell us about your
experience using them?
CHRIS KOCH: I use Google
Maps all the time.
I do have Gmail.
Aw, I completely forgot.
I was going to, at the very
beginning of my presentation,
say, sorry, I just have to
check my Hotmail really quickly.
But I forgot to do that.
So yeah, I use a lot
of the Google-- Maps,
translator-- I love
Google Translate.
That has come in very, very
handy on numerous occasions.
I would say, other
than Maps, Translate.
Good job on Translate.
Anybody here work on that?
Thank you.
MALE SPEAKER: And
last question--
Chris, what are some of
the toughest obstacles you
face in your day to day life?
Can technology help to
alleviate some of them?
CHRIS KOCH: Such
simple, little things.
Ironing my shirt-- I once
bit my lip ironing my shirt.
So obviously, I
was doing it wrong.
When I stay in hotels,
especially if I'm there
on my own, I don't know why.
I think it's because when
the cleaners are in before
and they're washing
out the shower,
they turn the shower head
off, put it off to the side
so the shower's not
going right on them
and then they forget
to tip it back.
So when I get in and
that shower head's
pointed against the
wall-- so I have
to shower underneath the
faucet or something like that.
So, just tiny little
things-- and I mean,
I've used broom handles
and my skateboard,
stood up on the side of
the tub held my skateboard
and tipped the shower head
to-- where there's a will,
there's a way.
You'll figure out a way.
I've used an ironing board
to move the shower head.
But it's way easier
to just ask Ally, hey,
do you mind moving
the shower head?
When I was traveling
with Anna in Asia,
I couldn't even
turn the shower on,
because all the taps
were up so high.
So I would hide
in behind the door
and she would come in
with her eyes closed
and turn the shower on
and then run back out
and hopefully not hit the
wall and find the doorway
and then shower.
And then when I was done,
[INAUDIBLE] she'd do that.
So yeah, good friends
also help out.
MALE SPEAKER: So, thank you
so much, Chris, for coming.
CHRIS KOCH: Thanks again.
[APPLAUSE]